would you rather Bowl the more or Freddy
Krueger I just wanted to let you know
that if you and your team can 100
million slugs by December 23rd I will
double the charity money really yeah
well times
Voldemort that means that I'm in a world
of Wizarding and magic and that would
mean that I had at some point gotten
enough training in magic to Voldemort
unless I'm just going up fisticuff like
hey buddy yeah your bald head over I'm
gonna fit in you know
good you didn't want to be you didn't
want to clear me yeah well this is
[ __ ] you're making I'm busy right
you have done anything I know but I'm
just like oh hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm about to be be
challenger oh oh oh but if you're Freddy
Krueger that's horrible I've seen the
movies that does not end well for
anybody there was a whole group of
pilgrims that had just gotten done
everything on the island
is there something in there that wants
to come out and meet probably that is a
lovely right above my head always
letting marga buyer first I'm hoping now
that I have you know my friends to me
that I'm gonna have a lot more time to
do the things that I want to do Ross
unleashed his all over all over just
covered and oh so much goopy everywhere
that's that's what Ross did when he was
making this level he just sprayed his
all over it and that's all we have left
to go by Oh God Oh a dog say a sentence
that's exactly seven syllables long go I
like up my butt